hi I'm Leslie I'm a blogger if you want  to know how to style curly hair keep on  watching to keep my hair super  moisturized I like to co wash instead of  using a shampoo and I love to use bumble  and bumble bee bee curl custom  conditioner this leaves my hair super  soft and really hydrated my hair is  naturally very dry so often I'll use a  mask afterwards too to boost the  hydration I love to use evader dry  remedy moisturizing marsan I rank the  product in with my fingers and I don't  hold back to lock in moisture and add  shine I finished off with a Veda dry  remedy daily moisturizing oil to dry my  hair I use the fabulous Speed Pro blow  dryer with diffuser this is great at  frizz control and keeping my hair smooth  finally I use my hands to fluff up and  shake my hair for more videos like this  subscribe to glamour UK's YouTube  channel  [Music]